oui
[Musique]
bonjour nous sommes en direct et
commençons l'interview du ministre russe
des affaires étrangères sergueï lavrov
avec la chaîne russia today
nous avons avec nos cinq rédactions de
différentes langues de la chaîne je vous
propose de commencer par les questions
de la rédaction allemande nous avons
avec nous romain sisskin je sais que
malheureusement des nouvelles pas très
positive arrive de votre front c'est un
vrai champ de bataille informationnel
des obstacles sont imposés au
fonctionnement normal du service
germanophone la partie allemande sap
votre travail je vous en prie votre
question vos commentaires la parole est
à vous
bonjour monsieur lavrov madame makarova
comme vous le savez arte a lancé sa
télédiffusion en allemand une semaine à
peine à passer et le signal de notre
chaîne a été supprimé du satellite
eutelsat neuf sous pression du
régulateur allemand
on menace de nous traîner en justice et
de nous fermer
youtube de son côté a supprimé la chaîne
le jour de son lancement le ministre
russe des affaires étrangères est il au
courant de la situation des actions
concrètes sont elles prévues pour
soutenir la chaîne et nos journalistes
oui nous sommes au courant de la
situation
la porte parole du ministère russe des
affaires étrangères maria zakharova la
commenter à plusieurs reprises
nous suivons de près le travail de nos
journalistes à l'étranger
compte tenu des cas répétés de
discrimination
rts boutiques n'ont toujours pas
d'accréditation auprès de l'elysée
le président russe vladimir poutine a
souligné récemment se fait dans une
conversation téléphonique avec le
président français emmanuel macron
espérons que nos collègues français
ferait tout pour que les médias russes y
compris rt travail en france d'une
manière aussi confortable que les médias
français en russie
nous voulons que ce même principe soit
appliquée à l'égard de rt en allemagne
et à l'égard de n'importe quel autre
média russe étant discriminés étrange et
le cas de l'allemagne est scandaleux
dès le début les autorités allemandes
ont tout fait pour créer une image
négative de la chaîne dans la société
allemande et auprès des structures
officielles
malgré les tentatives des responsables
officiels de prendre du recul quant aux
actions des régulateurs
il ya d'abord eu des tentatives de
bloquer les services bancaires
ensuite il y a eu un refus
d'enregistrement
l'interdiction au luxembourg
désormais nos collègues en serbie ont
enregistré la chaîne rt en allemand en
conformité avec la convention européenne
sur la télévision transfrontières dont
l'allemagne fait partie il faut la
respecter
ils vont apparemment mettre la
responsabilité sur les réseaux sociaux
sur youtube disons que c'est leur
initiative personnelle qu'ils ont
prétendument leurs propres critères et
que le gouvernement n'a rien à voir avec
cela
il a tout à fait quelque chose à voir
avec cela car l'allemagne avaient signé
et s'était chargé de respecter toutes
les obligations
l'engageant à assurer la liberté d'accès
à l'information
c'est à l'état sur le territoire duquel
a lieu cet arbitrage est pas youtube
qu'incombe la responsabilité de mettre
fin à cela
la discrimination visant les médias
russes a cours depuis des années
nous avons souvent eu la tentation de
répondre de la même manière par des
actions réciproques
mais jusqu'à récemment
dans cette situation nous étions sûrs de
ne pas vouloir suivre la même voie d'
asphyxie de la presse et des médias
comme le font nos partenaires
occidentaux
mais tout comme dans le cas de la
sécurité de la russie qu'il faut assurer
la patience a ses limites
je n'exclus pas que si cette situation
inacceptable se poursuit
nous serons obligés de répondre
de la rédaction espagnol à vous la
parole
bonjour madame makarova monsieur lavrov
ma question porte sur notre région
nombre d'événements d'importance ont eu
lieu en amérique latine cette année la
récente élection au chili a par exemple
été remporté par leurs représentants des
forces politiques de gauche gabriel
boric il y a aussi eu la victoire de la
gauche au honduras la gauche a également
gardé le pouvoir au nicaragua et au
venezuela mais en même temps les états
unis continuent de considérer cette
région comme leurs zones d'intérêt le
changement de cap politique dans ces
pays est il selon vous un signe que
l'amérique latine devient plus
indépendante d'un point de vue politique
ou comme le croient les américains la
région restera sous leur patronage que
c'est leur ventre mou et qu'elle restera
guidés par les règles établies par les
états unis dans l'esprit du récent
sommet pour la démocratie
depuis ces dernières 50 60 ans voire
plus
l'amérique latine a subi des changements
dans le paysage politique en alternant
entre la gauche et la droite
il y a désormais une nouvelle vague
d'arrivée au pouvoir de force n orienté
sur la nation
je pense que cela reflète la tendance
générale 2 défaites grave du projet
néolibéral
je voudrais souligner la chose suivante
la russie n'a jamais modifié ses actions
dans ses relations avec l'amérique
latine en fonction du gouvernement
arrivant au pouvoir
nous voulons développer l'amitié la
coopération mutuellement avantageuse
avec les pays et les peuples et non avec
tel ou tel gouvernement en fonction de
ses préférences politiques
à la différence des états unis nous ne
considérons pas l'amérique latine comme
un terrain de jeu géopolitique
l'administration américaine actuelle ne
reproduit plus les déclarations de
l'ancien conseiller à la sécurité
nationale de donald trump john bolton
selon qui la doctrine monroe est
toujours la norme
mais quand il s'agit des affaires
politiques ce cap cette mentalité se
fait toujours sentir dans la politique
concrète promu par les états unis
nous travaillons sans exception avec
tous les pays et les organisations sous
régionales dont la région de l'amérique
latine et des caraïbes
pour la seule année dernière j'ai eu des
contacts avec mes collègues du mexique
du venezuela de bolivie du brésil du
guatemala du nicaragua du honduras de
tubas du belize
j'ai rencontré les représentants du
système d'intégration d'amérique
centrale en marge de la session de
l'assemblée générale de l'onu à new york
j'ai également eu une rencontre avec mon
homologue argentin en marge du g20
nous soulignons toujours que nous avons
intérêt à avoir une coopération
dépolitiser pour ce qui est des
relations bilatérales
concernant les structures et
organisations multilatérales
nous allons comme la majorité des pays
d'amérique latine défendre les valeurs
les normes les objectifs et les
principes de la charte de l'onu
l'année dernière à l'initiative du
venezuela a été formé le groupe d'amitié
pour la défense de la charte des nations
unies
il a rapidement réuni plus de 20 membres
je suis persuadé que des pays notamment
d'amérique latine vont aussi rejoindre
ce mécanisme
il répond dans une certaine mesure aux
tentatives américaines et de leurs
alliés les plus proches de s'éloigner du
droit international et de s'appuyer dans
leurs déclarations dans leurs arguments
et dans leur politique sur un ordre basé
sur les règles qui l'ont inventée par
eux mêmes
ces règles sont formulées dans un cercle
étroit où personne ne représente de
point de vue alternatif où il n'y a pas
de discussion
ce qui implique que la vérité ne peut
pas en découler
en même temps je vois que
l'administration actuelle des états unis
commencent à envisager ce qui se passe
d'une manière un peu plus pragmatique
elle commence à considérer d'autres
actions à l'égard du venezuela
elle se rend compte petit à petit qu'il
faudra tout de même mené un dialogue
avec le gouvernement du président
nicholas maduro qui a réaffirmé son
mandat après l'élection
la situation est similaire en bolivie où
la vraie démocratie a été restauré après
des actions assez douteuse des
précédents aux autorités
j'espère que washington reconnaîtra et
comprendra la réalité d'un pays comme le
nicaragua
nous soutenons une situation où des
puissances externes favoriserait
activement la formation d'une identité
latino américaine
celle des caraïbes comme l'un des grands
et importants paul de l'ordre mondial
polycentrique qui est en train de se
former
nous apprécions nos relations avec les
structures régionales et sous régionales
de la région surtout avec la communauté
des états d'amérique latine et des
caraïbes la celac
avec laquelle nous avons un mécanisme de
consultations politiques
nous avons fait une petite pause à cause
de la pandémie
à l'heure actuelle le mexique gère la
présidence de la celac et les mexicains
voudrait reprendre ses réunions
nous allons soutenir activement cette
intention
parmi les domaines où nous coopérons on
peut citer les hautes technologies
l'énergie l'agriculture bien sûr
l'espace le nucléaire la médecine la
santé
plusieurs pays d'amérique latine dont le
mexique le brésil l'argentine le
nicaragua ont déjà reçu la technologie
pour la production des vaccins russe
il exploite activement et se prépare à
lancer la production
je pense que les contacts appropriés
donneront un élan à une coopération plus
large
transversale
dans le domaine pharmaceutique
celui de la santé publique et de la
médecine
midi sonne
la rédaction arabe est représenté
aujourd'hui par maximale tueur et votre
question
merci madame makarova bonjour monsieur
lavrov notre public arabophone de
plusieurs millions de téléspectateurs
voudrais vous poser de nombreuses
questions mais malheureusement nous
avons un temps limité nous ne pouvons
pas vous poser toutes ces questions
j'aimerais vous parler de l'iran
l'occident continue d'accuser l'iran de
poursuivre une escalade nucléaire ce qui
pourrait selon lui conduire à l'échec
des négociations dans le cadre du traité
de vienne sur le nucléaire iranien
téhéran affirme de son côté que l'union
européenne désinforme au lieu de mener
des négociations sérieuses quelle est la
position de la russie et que faut-il
pour que ces négociations aboutissent à
mon grand regret nos partenaires
occidentaux essaient de déformer les
faits
l'administration de donald trump s'est
retirée de tous les accords de l'accord
de vienne sur le nucléaire iranien et de
la résolution du conseil de sécurité qui
l'a prouvé mais c'est encore une fois
l'iran qui est coupable
lorsque donald trump a fait cela
les iraniens n'ont pris aucune mesure
contredisant leurs obligations dans le
cadre de l'accord de vienne pendant plus
d'un an
c'est seulement quand il est devenu
clair que la décision de washington et
est irréversible que les iraniens ont
commencé à utiliser les opportunités
prévu dans l'accord même
et qui concernait les engagements
volontaires de téhéran sur divers
aspects de son programme nucléaire
ils ont limité et cessé de remplir
uniquement les engagements volontaires
ils ont à chaque fois souligné oui nous
augmentons le pourcentage
d'enrichissement ou lançons la
production de centrifugeuses
technologiquement plus avancés
mais dès que les états unis retourneront
pleinement au respect de leurs
obligations
notre réaction ne se fera pas attendre
alors c'est sur ce principe
sur cette compréhension que se font
désormais les pourparlers qui se déroule
à vienne
d'avril à juin six séances de
négociations ont eu lieu au cours
desquelles les américains et les
iraniens ne se sont pas mis directement
autour de la table
ce sont le groupe de coordinateur du
service extérieur européens et les
délégations chinoises russes françaises
allemandes et britanniques qui y ont
travaillé
de manière générale à la suite de ces
six séances a été élaboré un certain
ensemble d'entente permettant d'espérer
que nous serons à l'avenir tout de même
en mesure de parvenir à un accord final
ensuite il y a eu une pause inévitable
du au processus de formation d'un
nouveau gouvernement en iran suite aux
élections à ce moment nos collègues
occidentaux ont fait preuve d'une
certaine nervosité
d'impatience appelant l'iran à faire
tout cela dans les plus brefs délais
mais nous leur avons rappelé que l'iran
attendait depuis plus d'un an que les
américains reviennent à cette
compréhension cette attente n'a pas
porté ses fruits alors l'iran s'est
retiré ensuite il y a eu le programme
électoral tout cela est très clair je ne
dramatise ray pas trop quoi que ce soit
il est clair que l'équipe iranienne
actuelle est une nouvelle équipe mais
ils ont très vite et je dirais de
manière professionnelle pris en main le
sujet ils ont élaboré des propositions
qui ont d'abord été accueillie avec
hostilité par certains représentants
occidentaux
qui ont fini par admettre que ces
propositions avaient le droit d'exister
et d'être étudié c'est exactement ainsi
que le travail est menée actuellement
les problèmes qui sont apparus n'était
pas de fonds mais d'image qui doit être
le premier à dire ça y est je respecte
de nouveau mes engagements les états
unis où l'iran l'iran était convaincu
que c'était aux américains de le faire
car ce sont les américains qui se sont
retirés en premier du traité de vienne
sur le nucléaire iranien
et les américains considéraient que
l'iran avait commencé à manquer à ses
engagements et que c'était à l'iran de
faire le premier pas
indépendamment du fait que washington ne
respectait pas du tout ses propres
engagements
avec nos amis chinois et avec une
certaine compréhension de la part des
représentants européens nous nous sommes
prononcés en faveur de la
synchronisation de ce mouvement pour
qu'il y ait un ensemble de pas à faire
des deux côtés c'est bien là dessus que
travaille actuellement les négociateurs
à vienne ils ont fait une courte pause
pour le noël catholique mais ces
négociations vont reprendre avant la fin
de l'année lire on confirme que si les
états unis se mettent à respecter
pleinement leur engagement cessent de
menacer de sanctions incompatible avec
le traité de vienne sur le nucléaire
iranien et la résolution 2231 lire on
recommencera alors à remplir pleinement
ses obligations y compris l'application
d'un protocole additionnel à l'accord de
garanties généralisées avec l' agence
internationale de l'énergie atomique
dont je pense que nous avons de bonnes
chances et là bien sûr il est important
de garder à l'esprit le principe sur
lequel ce travail est fondé et avec
lequel tout le monde est d'accord rien
n'est convenu tant que tout n'est pas
convenu il faut donc un ensemble de
mesures correctes bien équilibrée et
c'est tout à fait réaliste
c'est le temps de donner la parole à la
rédaction française s'il vous plaît
virag hoffman
merci beaucoup maria bonjour monsieur
lavrov je voudrais vous demander de
commenter la déclaration du ministre
français des affaires étrangères jean
yves le drian comme vous le savez il a
mis en garde les autorités russes contre
des conséquences extrêmement graves en
cas d'invasion de l'ukraine par la
russie pourquoi selon vous la
communication avec les gouvernements
occidentaux prend tel depuis peu la
forme d'incessantes menace
c'est peut-être plus tôt à eux qu'il
faut poser cette question
cela ne me fait aucun plaisir mais cela
ne suscite pas non plus en moi
d'émotions négatives
nous sommes habitués au fait que nos
collègues occidentaux nous prennent de
haut et fasse constamment des
déclarations montrant qu'ils se
considèrent comme les maîtres du destin
et comme des hommes politiques
irréprochables parfaitement sûr d'avoir
raison
nous avons entendu à plusieurs reprises
des déclarations des dirigeants français
selon lesquels il mène un dialogue
exigeant avec la russie selon lesquelles
ils vont exiger quelque chose de nous et
les voilà en train d'exiger
mais il me semble qu'au cours de ces
dernières semaines le président russe et
d'autres hauts fonctionnaires russes ont
abordé à plusieurs reprises le sujet de
la prétendue escalade pour laquelle les
occidentaux menace de nous punir
il me semble qu'ils ont déjà préparé un
pack de sanctions juste au cas où pour
être utilisés à l'avenir il y a existé
désormais de tels services sur les
réseaux sociaux on achète quelque chose
en magasin pour une utilisation
ultérieure
c'est probablement du point de vue de
nos collègues occidentaux également
applicables en politique
nous avons expliqué à maintes reprise ce
que font nos forces armées sur notre
propre territoire
en même temps nous avons aussi posé la
question ce que font les américains les
canadiens et les britanniques que font
leurs équipements militaires de guerre
et leurs avions de combat aux frontières
de la fédération de russie en
particulier dans les pays baltes
et que font leurs navires qui sillonnent
la mer noire à busan gravement des
normes fixées par la convention de
montreux
en réponse nous n'entendons aucune
explication intelligible mais que des
menaces des menaces et encore des
menaces
je pense que au lieu de menacer sans
raison nos collègues européens devraient
assumer leurs responsabilités la france
dans ce cas avec l'allemagne doit bien
sûr force et kiev à se conformer aux
accords de minsky à ne pas détourner
l'attention comme qui est fait c'est de
le faire en utilisant comme écran de
fumée les accusations contre la russie
selon lesquels nous serions en train
d'attiser la situation est sur le point
de conquérir soit le dombass entier soit
une partie du dombass soit toute
l'ukraine c'est évident
de la même manière zelensky et son
régime ne cesse d'attiser les tensions
concernant la grille mais ce n'était pas
le cas il ya quelques années
il y a quelques années les gens
espéraient encore que kiev serait en
mesure de mettre en oeuvre les accords
de minsk ce que céline ce qu'ils avaient
promis en se portant candidat à la
présidence
mais quand il est devenu président il a
compris qu'il ne voulait pas ou qu'il ne
pouvait pas ou que les néo nazis et
autres ultras radicaux ne le laisserait
pas faire c'est alors que afin de
détourner l'attention du fait qu'ils
sont complètement incapable de mettre en
oeuvre les accords de minsk le sujet de
la crimée a immédiatement surgit comme
principal symbole de la politique
étrangère ukrainienne
d'où la plateforme de crimée et tout ce
qui va avec
ce sont des paroles creuses des paroles
en l'air
tout le monde le comprend très bien y
compris nos collègues occidentaux qui
joue avec ce jouet
or ce qu'il devrait faire réellement
sans aucun jeu c'est forcé et dance qui
à se conformer à la résolution 2202 du
conseil de sécurité de l'onu approuvant
les accords de minsk dans ces accords il
est clairement indiqué qui doit faire
quoi et dans quel ordre
il s'agit de kiev de donetsk et de
lougansk à saubusse amnistie statut
spécial
organisation d'élections avec les
modalités convenues entre kiev donetsk
est lougansk est sous les auspices de
l'organisation pour la sécurité et la
coopération en europe
et seulement après viendra le
rétablissement du contrôle des forces
armées ukrainiennes sur toute la
longueur des frontières à l'heure
actuelle il propose de faire le
contraire vous nous laissez la frontière
et nous verrons si nos mettrons en place
une sorte de procédure d'octroi du
statut spécial
ou si nous aurons recours à d'autres
solutions sur la politique d'état de la
période de transition c'est la
proposition de loi dont le président
poutine a parlé à plusieurs reprises au
président emmanuel macron et à la
chancelière angela merkel et hier
également au chancelier olaf scholz elle
a été déposée par le gouvernement
ukrainien à la rada ce projet de loi
comporte une interdiction pour les
autorités ukrainiennes de mettre en
oeuvre les accords de minsk au lieu
d'une amnistie elle prévoit une
épuration au lieu d'un statut spécial
une administration civilo militaire sans
aucune élection spéciale convenu avec
cette partie de l'ukraine juste le
rétablissement du contrôle sur les
territoires occupés comme il le déclare
malgré les promesses des français et des
allemands de dissuader zelensky de
promouvoir cette loi ils introduisent
déjà activement dans le processus
législatif
le conseil de l'europe a été sollicité à
cet effet la commission de venise leur a
dit que tout allait bien il y à quelques
commentaires concernant les aspects
juridiques mais la commission de venise
n'a pas dit un mot sur le fait que ce
projet de loi contredisait directement
la résolution du conseil de sécurité de
l'onu c'est pour cette raison que je
demande de manière insistante à mon bon
camarade jean yves le drian
à mes collègues allemands j'ai rencontré
anna lena berlocq en marge du conseil de
l'organisation pour la sécurité et la
coopération en europe elle s'est
également montré intéressé par la mise
en oeuvre des accords de minsk comme on
dit c'est dieu lui-même qui dit de s'en
occuper
cela leur permettra peut-être de se
détourner de leurs préoccupations
artificielle concernant une escalade
inexistante
la rédaction anglaise s'il vous plaît
daniel quel est votre question
merci je voudrais poursuivre le sujet
évoqué par ma collègue de la chaîne
française les médias occidentaux comme
vous le savez continue d'attiser les
tensions concernant la crise ukrainienne
cnn par exemple parle depuis longtemps
de milliers de soldats russes à la
frontière ukrainienne vous avez déclaré
à plusieurs reprises qu'un tel
hâtivement constitua une opération
spéciale est à cet égard en novembre la
russie a fait un pas sans précédent en
publiant sa correspondance diplomatique
avec la france et l'allemagne
on a dit alors que cela avait été fait
pour que la position de la russie sur le
processus de paix en ukraine ne soit pas
déformée
dites moi cette publication at elle
produit l'effet escompté
nous je suis sûr
que cette démarche
n'a pas été entreprise en vain
je le dirai ainsi je n'essaie pas de
faire appel à la conscience de qui que
ce soit de faire que qui que ce soit se
sent honteux
nous travaillons dans le domaine de la
diplomatie
les émotions ne sont probablement pas
ici le meilleur des conseillers ce qu'il
faut comme le disait l'un de mes
collègues c'est un cynisme st
mais du point de vue du cynisme sein les
négociations questions sont très
révélatrices
elle réfute complètement les
affirmations précédent le fait que nous
ayons révéler nos cartes selon
lesquelles la russie bloquerait le
travail du format normandie de toutes
les manières possibles
ce n'est pas vrai ou faux nous sommes
très inquiet que kiev des formes et
détourne les accords de minsk la chieuse
je les ai déjà dit en répondant à la
question précédente mais aussi que les
français et les allemands en tant que
coauteur de ce document
en tant que participant au format
normandie commence à prendre à 100% le
parti du régime ukrainien
si auparavant il nous disait que les
accords de minsk était incontestable et
que tout le monde devait les respecter
désormais lisez le
je ne me souviens pas à quelle date le
12 octobre semble-t-il il y a eu un
sommet ukraine eu au cours duquel il a
été déclaré que la russie devrait et que
kiev faisait ce qu'il fallait ce qu'il
devait faire aussi bien au format
normandie que dans le cadre du groupe de
contact
récemment le président céline ce qui a
rencontré les dirigeants allemand et
français en marge du sommet du
partenariat oriental à bruxelles
l'a finalement ils ont également exprimé
leur plein soutien aux actions de kiev
concernant la mise en oeuvre des accords
de minsk
c'est que soient nos collègues ont
reconnu leur incapacité à assurer la
mise en oeuvre de ce qu'ils avaient eux
mêmes élaboré avec nous soit ils ont
décidé de saper délibérément les accords
de minsk par complaisance envers le
régime de kiev vous gourdon jusqu'au
bout de jours chers collègues merci
beaucoup pour votre participation
ainsi s'achève cette interview qui est à
mon avis elle ressemblait plutôt à une
conférence de presse mais c'était très
intéressant merci merci merci à vous
[Musique]